this episode is brought to you by Red
Bull sound select guess what Red Bull
gives you wings you know what else they
give you to give you 30 days in Chicago
and it's a month-long celebration of
Chicago's music community and it sounds
of tomorrow I've already been to a
couple of these shows it's real nice
real good times go check out the
exclusive videos shows photos all that
good stuff
at 30 days dot Red Bull sound select
calm that's 3 0 days dot Red Bull sound
select calm or just start following Red
Bull sound select on Facebook Twitter
and Instagram also on December 29th of
year in Chicago pitchfork reacting
October are throwing a show with me
Hannibal and Thundercat Thundercats dope
if you haven't seen them live you got to
check them out and it's going to be a
Chicago Civic Opera House it's going to
be on a Friday that's December 29th at 8
p.m. there's gonna be like a beer
tasting I'm gonna do like my little
video DJ set you know what Hannibal does
Thundercat is amazing bass player singer
is gonna be a dope show don't sleep on
his [ __ ] tickets are still on sale go to
Ticketmaster get tickets and come see us
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome thank you for having me thanks
for being here it's another episode the
Parkers Hanson ramble your host Hannibal
Buress co-hosts
tawny trim with our special guest
Mitsuki Haim it's risky hi what's up I'm
good how are you I'm doing all right
thanks for coming on the show it's my
pleasure my honor
yeah thank you it's fun it's a fun time
we're glad we're glad sure you're here
we were at the show last night packed
our show
Lincoln Hall Red Bull Red Bull Red Bull
shout out the Red Bull Empire gives you
aims hey who knew they didn't know back
in the 70s who knew that's such a
I'm sorry Red Boy I've I'm just gonna
say this
who knew that like a drink that smells
like chemical fumes would make it this
big this I mean yes it's an industry now
I think they are probably shot sometimes
yo we're still going mm-hmm
this episode sponsored by rebel
what is a relationship redbull without
some honesty Red Bull vodkas making
everyone crazy worldwide is that still a
thing do people still do Red Bull vodkas
yeah like in me maybe in New Jersey I
don't know no some people do it
I actually I forget who recently that's
blackout central I offered to buy a girl
a drink
and she asked for a Red Bull vodka you
feel oh yeah yeah yeah get her uh you
know it's funny
it was at a bar at a casino in Vegas so
uh had a drink ticket yeah and so I had
my drink was covered by the drink ticket
and then I said hey Red Bull vodka and
then uh they said that's not a drink
ticket drink yeah so I had to come out I
didn't so you had a PBR instead no I had
to pee no don't worry about it we pay
for your Red Bull vodka babe I got this
you played a show there I mean not
played a show did a gig I don't know
what the terminology is for comedy the
same played a show did a gig and as is
no I was just chillin oh nice but you
still gave you drink tickets that's when
you gamble when you gamble you never
gamble no I feel like my career is
already again boy I don't need to do any
more why you feel like your career is a
gamble commercial music he's gambling
every day you know these streets on the
road yes yeah yeah but I feel like
comedy must be harder actually with
music I don't know you can just exist at
a show and play music and have people
not pay attention to you and still get
paid but I feel like with comedy you
really need to be there and if you go
playing music you don't have to get any
reaction and still be killing it yeah
exactly but if you ain't getting laughs
yeah you're not doing your job dad yeah
I bail on shells though
me so oh I get out of there if it's
weird sometimes okay this is weird and
I'll say you guys are feeling that oz as
an audience I do more shows did you go
to shows and let me tell you you guys
are sticking it up right now
goodnight Cincinnati now kids Cincinnati
have had great shows but uh it could be
weird sometimes you know why everybody
thinks they're funny is it sometimes
people yell out well I mean I imagine
it's harder it's harder to be funny when
everyone's looking at you
like okay be funny it's easier like I
don't know it's easier for me to be
funny in a casual situation just because
no one's expecting me to be special yeah
so if I make a stupid joke everyone's
like ah she's a musician but she made a
joke with you it's like you gotta be
funny godmother yes this pressure
pressure yeah it could be worse things
then it's terrifying to me then doing a
bad joke you have to put it in
perspective it's tough but nobody's
brain is on the line I also feel like
homers in [ __ ] and not in play comedians
are so mean to each other I feel like in
music at least musicians kind of are
nice to each other but when I listen to
comedians talk to each other even good
friends they're like so shitty to each
other and they insult you touch each
other all the time and I can't I
couldn't handle that really I just want
people to be nice to me like why do you
why do you always insult each other why
can't you just beat your with sharp I
don't know I think dudes in general kind
of talk [ __ ] to each other
it's Tuesday good friends that I do or
it's like if you're from like a certain
kind of neighborhood or upbringing it's
like you just kind of roast each other
like me and my circle of friends would
always just roast each other oh I I mean
I've never had friends so I guess I
don't know
Oh friends so I guess I wouldn't know
you moved around a lot
yeah yes 13 13 times that was a number I
threw out randomly and then it's stuck
in the press but I actually don't know
you don't know yeah I never really
counted 13 times but you identify
somebody that moved 16 times what who
moved 16 times I did you move when
you're in high school I went to four
different high schools oh yeah see
that's where and uh freshman year was in
Japan tenth grade Alabama 11th grade
11th grade I actually ditched school and
didn't go to school for a year was I was
like I'm not learning anything I'm just
not gonna go so where were you in Japan
and then I just worked full-time and
then as I was working as a teenager with
a degree I was like oh you need to go to
school so that people don't treat you
like you're an idiot
and then so I went back to school and
that was in Virginia and then senior
year I was in Turkey and then I went to
college in New York okay the end so your
parents are spies well I mean I wouldn't
I wouldn't say yea or nay
yeah but they might be okay at least one
of them was a spy Turkey Africa Virginia
you say Alabama - yeah that was my
choice Alabama
yeah you said my dad and you say okay I
want to move to Alabama and then your
dad just hopped on LinkedIn looking for
smart ops you know went to Alabama alone
my family was in Japan but there is a
performing arts school in Alabama that I
wanted to go to so I went alone
Birmingham yeah
nice you live with a roommate at fifteen
or sixteen tenth grade yeah yeah
fifteen whoa that's pretty ballsy
Alabama of all places - I had no fear
now looking back I'm like damn it I had
I did all those things I was so stupid
that's stupid that's great
you got like a a very huge wide view now
yes in Alabama there people say to use
you look kind of white but not really no
no no I was small to China no she's like
almost but not sorta I was like almost
no people didn't give me any white
privilege I was firmly the Asian girl oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's the thing in
the u.s. I'm the Asian girl in Japan I'm
the white girl can't win like oh my oh
my Korean family look at me as the
[ __ ] yeah and then and here you're
the Asian guy yeah here it's like yeah
my my Asian friend I want to talk more
about this year off of school in Japan
where were you working what was that
like how did it change you besides
learning that you needed to well we're
really getting personal in this in this
interview well I just I was in school
but I was I hated it I felt like I
wasn't learning anything I felt like I
could teach myself more than I was
learning in school so I was like [ __ ] it
Oh am I allowed to swear in this
absolutely I was I was like [ __ ] it at
any time there's a law we'll just
out of it and then I so I worked as a
waitress at a Korean barbecue place and
on weekends I'd go to like museums I go
to go on little day trips to other parts
of Japan
I learned to party a little bit in Japan
it's safer learn to party whoa okay okay
anyway and and then after a while I
realized that you know actually being in
the working world people treated me like
[ __ ] cuz I didn't even have a degree I
was just a high schooler not in school
and I was like oh like it's not about
learning anything in school it's just
getting that degree so I was like I need
to go back to school to get a degree you
could have made a degree up really I
don't know I wasn't that smart I guess I
was doing music throughout all this no
no I had no hope or ambition in life
because I didn't I love music but I
didn't realize I could do it like I
didn't imagine I could actually be a
musician so where did that come into
play that came into play senior year of
high school I graduated early I
graduated I took a year off but
graduated early yeah well I went I went
to I went to a military base school and
so I had way like I had enough credits
to graduate so I got there took a few
like months and I was like wait I I can
graduate I don't need to be here I went
up to the principal I was like can I
just get out of here you don't want me
here I don't want to be here
yeah and they made a deal yeah and they
took it they took it they let me out
that's great and that's when I started
to do music cuz I had all this time on
my hands yeah
so you picked up a guitar taught
yourself no I started playing guitar in
college I played piano oh okay okay
yeah did your dad ever try to get you to
be a Navy SEAL like him
no she was like no honey it's a hard
life you don't want this yeah you know I
don't want you to die you got any
siblings
I have one little sister yeah he's all
right yeah yeah was the last time you
were in Japan last year for a tour yeah
mm-hmm that's pretty nice they're a
whole different market have you been to
Japan once where'd he go
just Tokyo you should go outside of
Tokyo when you go back to Japan you
should go to the west side the west side
yeah of Japan Tokyo's on the east side
the west side it's like people are
funnier they're friendlier they're more
open all foreigners like the west side
more you should go to like Kyoto and
Osaka okay so where you're from kinda
I'm on the west you're born in Japan
right yeah but I was born in Mia which
is just like nowhere countryside okay so
would it be equivalent East Coast and
West Coast of America where people
consider the west coast of the States to
be more laid-back in the east coast to
be more uptight and aggressive mmm I'm
trying to think of the analogy I don't
know well there's more history right
well also in Tokyo people I feel like
are very varied Japanese I feel like
they're so reserved people don't talk to
each other it's pretty crowded and kind
of grey and it's very City Vice stuff
your city vibe but I get stuffed into a
train
stuffed don't they do that don't they do
that but that's during rush hour yeah
yeah they also have women only trains
because because there's a lot of there's
so much sexual here I've seen like the
signs where it just shows like a guy's
hand like going up the skirt yeah yeah
and a lot of like like hidden pictures
of upskirt pictures and stuff there's a
lot of that training RV pervy let me do
another setting here one thing I did
enjoy being in Japan being in Tokyo was
that I couldn't read anything you
enjoyed that yes so I was you know
normally is advertisements and all
there's a noise mm-hmm coming into your
brain and you're just looking at this
mat and it was just I know none of that
[ __ ] so I was able to kind of just be
your own prayers my thoughts but you
know what's crazy about the Japanese
language Japanese culture is that the
fonts are usually really big bubbly and
crazy you know when you see like a
Japanese product you might not know what
it is but it always looks exciting yeah
like this what can you do that again I
didn't hear
Tokyo to me just looks like a huge
pinball machine mm-hmm I haven't been
there but doesn't every time I see all
the pictures pictures movies whatever
that's what it looks like it's like ah
you've never been no I've want to go I
was supposed to go last year I was gonna
go there and Seoul but we ended up doing
a large tour yeah oh my gosh Seoul is
coming up South Korea yes coming up the
music everything style yeah yeah yeah
Carmen Sandiego try it but do you know
first one to really push South Korea
really represents yes Korea wet wet in
the world is Carmen Sandiego
what if Carmen Sandiego was like yo I'm
at the crib muhfuckas chillin I'm just
at home what do you want
what garden apartment hanging out with
my family she's in one oversized t-shirt
just like looking for where in the world
is Carmen Sandiego I'm depressed right
now can you send some snacks and then
where it's please yeah how many stamps
on your passport is your passport crazy
it's pretty crazy
Pat you got your passport with you yeah
no I don't know you don't yeah it's at
my OB MB sorry but I can assure you
there are a lot of strings one time I
was in Germany and this guy this border
guy was like so you've been around a lot
in HoN I was like just let me go ya
don't want his talk yeah I bet you seem
so you travel a lot you've moved around
a lot do you uh is your where's your
residence yeah I don't live anywhere I
was gonna that's what I was getting it
you seem like you probably don't have a
lot of stuff I don't I don't and I also
don't have a place to live actually I
haven't for the past couple of years
you look pretty clean yep
I make enough money to get hotels and
Airbnb and stuff yeah yeah but that's
like that's like cuz I don't pay rent
like I don't have rent so instead of
rent I can just pay for wherever I'm
staying at that time
nice yeah I just I toured so much after
I used to live some I used to live in
New York but I was like it's not worth
it I've never at this apartment that I'm
paying exorbitant amounts of money for
what was your New York rent it was
$1,000 and I had a roommate and that was
excessive
yeah thousand with a roommate thousand
four digits just to still have another
person another person somebody else got
a shared bathroom for $1,000 that's not
a good deal I know so I got out of there
yeah did for you yeah on the road on the
road do you do you have do you kind of
Mythology as yourself is just as lonely
wandering traveler you travel with a
band I travel with a band yeah but
sometimes I play solo shows when they
didn't cover in the bay yes College
shows I do solo yeah because they pay a
lot and that I I can just be like I'm
gonna come solo in they're just they're
their kids so they're like okay yeah oh
I love your college show stories like
the one you told about the them
publishing how much they paid you yeah
they still they do that still happens
every now and it but I think they have
to report it oh do they in their college
we don't have to wear has to be the
students have to know because it's out
of their their fee so they've they've
all I've seen it in college papers more
recently College shows are wild just
because if you think about it you take a
bunch of children who are just learning
to do their laundry and the school is
like here's a [ __ ] ton of money go
entertain yourselves right yeah yes it's
extremely fascinating there you know
lots of artists financial security is
based on the web a 19 year old
I love it
Thanks colleges please book me like
college you know it I think I've had a
shift recently you like them no no I
used to like you always been kind of
look you appreciate the money but you're
probably at a point where you cannot
play a college show and still make money
like for start band starting out like if
it wasn't a college show they'd be paid
like $25 or like beer or pizza but then
suddenly you get this college show and
it's like hundreds or thousands of
dollars but you probably already get
paid enough not to do college shows
anyway I don't I think they see that I'm
aging my sensibility has shifted so I
don't the officers don't come in you get
aged out in the in the comedy world I
thought it was just female musician that
aged out but my it used to be where I
could just do a college show and just be
able I could do it in the middle of a
run yeah regular shows and do it and now
over the past year or so it have well
okay I'm doing a college show mm-hmm let
me sit down and figure out how we're
approaching this cuz I might say so some
[ __ ] a thirtysomething year-old says
that goes way this out got to cut this
out they've never rented a car before
they don't body on planes things that
just don't remember Saved by the Bell
get your snapchat material right wait so
what do you have to talk do you talk
about weed I talk about this go I
usually talk about their school okay how
much that tuition is we played the
school Washington University uh-huh and
so I was just you know researching them
before just to have some people I mean
in general as humans I think we like to
hear about ourselves and so I just
talked about how much they were paying
you got a fifty thousand a year they
were like no it's 60 well somebody needs
to update that Wikipedia this is 50
grand but the endowment that school
hasn't endow
in the billions huh where they could
they could pay the students tuition with
the endowment at least cut it in half
but why would they do that
why did you what did they just sit no I
don't want the kids to kill themselves
bill yes what what what yeah you know
like University of Chicago I remember
one of my homies is there when I was
going to college years back and they had
they would encourage people to throw
house parties because the suicide rate
was so high so they would just fund
parties and fund events so kids would be
happy and not kill themselves really
yeah but I mean the endowment that they
have when it's just money just sitting
yeah when you look at any school online
you look them up and he'll say this
school has an endowment of 3 billion
where's that go where's that for yeah
what are you doing with that really
they're just funding house party yes
well maybe yeah I mean I don't know what
problems some of it probably goes to
that to to keeping the kids happy
probably gonna pay for the tuition that
they're dead what swimming down in a
different stream than there okay but I
respect it we don't want kids to die
it's true we're on the same page on that
one yeah yeah just a couple of just a
couple of them couple of them need to
die right we don't know who but there's
some that's it die well this guy go do
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] they should go to
any university in Minnesota because I
hear about like caught like like
able-bodied healthy like pretty rich
college students go to school in like
Minneapolis or Minnesota and they die
because it's so cold like healthy
children
that's your random facts
[Laughter]
they these kids like go get drunk and
they're not used to being in such cold
weather and they get drunk they party
and then like they like I don't know
they leave their keys somewhere are they
they're drunk and they just like don't
know how to manage themselves and
they're out in the cold and they just
freeze to death out there like right in
front of their dorm room or something
how many but it's somewhere that just
sounds like stupidity yeah you know what
I'm not gonna you know I'm not gonna say
they deserve no one deserves to die
nobody deserves to die but if we had two
lives they deserve to lose one just to
learn definitely how about that they
don't deserve to die but it's like when
you play Mario Brothers last week
that's a weak move as a move you deserve
to lose a man okay I think they take
three lives I'm not gonna respond to
that just because I don't want on
tomorrow social media be like Mitsuki
wants people to die I'm gonna try not to
be controversial I mean you can't stop
my tweets yeah you won't believe what
she says we're gonna edit it to make it
just yeah
these are repeating I want people to die
did you make it track out of it cut it
I'm gonna cut it
[Music]
die
that's pretty good I think we have a hit
do you believe in the afterlife
I don't know but I love ghost stories if
you have any ghost stories please tell
them to me right now
I love ghost stories that's why
Halloween
I love Halloween should i I said oh no
squad just just hold it I love Halloween
because it's when like all the scary
stories come out on the internet yeah
yeah do you have any ghosts er I don't
have any no no haunted Airbnb I don't
believe in ghosts
what never experienced it I mean I don't
know if I believe in them but I just
love spooky stories me too I agree yeah
like uh so entertain me I don't have I
don't have a story for you you have a
ghost story
no have you ever experienced some kind
of a spiritual presence or weird [ __ ]
like that no I've been to one haunted
air baby I like to believe it's haunted
I don't know
we walked in it's in the middle of
nowhere California we walk in
immediately something's off
there's a [ __ ] rocking horse in the
middle of the living room like why would
you have that and then I go we it was
like 2:00 a.m. so we go upstairs me and
my band you got this okay good
and I go into the room that's supposed
to be mine and immediately there just
like a [ __ ] ton of just pictures of
soldiers like American soldiers
and then I I'm like okay well I'm just
sleepy I'm gonna try to go to sleep I
lie down I turn to my right there's a
gigantic fisheye mirror just like a
gigantic mirror right next to me as I'm
sleeping I can't avoid her fur and then
I look up and there's an obviously
sealed up attic door like really
obviously sealed up I'm like I'm not
gonna sleep here I go to the next room
where my band members are sleeping and
I'm like can I join you guys I crawl
into bed with one of the band members
and this room is just wall-to-wall dolls
all dolls just dolls shelves and shelves
and dolls and so my band member just
like gets scared and so she like turns
around a bunch of the scariest also
they're not facing us while we're
sleeping and then we finally fall asleep
and then while I'm kind of about to fall
asleep I hear people talking in the room
but I just assume it's my bed nurse and
I fall asleep and then in the morning I
talked to them I'm like were you like
awake talking at night and they were
like no why and I was like I I just
heard people talking in the room and
they're like no I heard it too oh but we
were all asleep and not talking they're
people in our room talking whoa so
that's our one haunted Airbnb hmm all
right one of my homies actually this is
a freaky story he was sleeping once and
he had a dream that he had a dream that
there were his clowns in his bedroom
like messing around and stuff and then
he woke up and he noticed that his
window was open and he knows all his
[ __ ] in his room was messed with and he
saw like three guys dressed in clown but
that's a ghost story that's just
freaking [ __ ] why clowns oh there is a
period I remember on the Internet
just like a bunch of scary clown yes
spottings well this is way before that
but okay yeah but that yeah people were
just randomly popping up in clown
outfits and terrorize yeah and I was
just thinking about how the movie it
really missed their mark because they
should have liked
come out right when that was happening
that was like perfect publicity for the
movie but they really [ __ ] that up
well movie was garbage anyways did you
like it
I've I've well all I'm gonna say is I
think it came out because Stephen King
watched stranger things and they're like
he was like what the [ __ ] that's what
I've been writing this whole time and so
he like hit up some studio people he was
like look we're gonna get it made
because stranger things I thought wait I
thought he was involved with the new it
too I thought was he not yeah I don't
was he I mean I know he wrote the
original one but I didn't I thought
maybe cuz it didn't seem like it's it
didn't it was a totally different
storyline I mean I haven't read the book
so I have I have no idea I haven't read
any Stephen King I've read I've read it
a long time ago like over it maybe like
20 years ago I read it so I don't
remember much about it but I do when I
was watching it I was just like wait a
minute this is not like the original
story at all but I might be wrong I
don't know did you you know I I went to
see it the weekend it came out but I
didn't want to see a matinee on a
Saturday but was your opinion on it you
know I went in to the theater not
realizing how sleepy I was so you slept
through it that's $18 I guess nothing
yes I fell asleep I fall asleep at
movies a lot he does it all the time
sometimes he just want to sleep in
public the movie theaters the best place
to do all asleep is on premiere so
really well it was after I died I did
about 40 interviews that day I know it's
just funny drinks to premiere started
late and then
I died in the movie but then when I saw
it you're like okay a body sent down my
body shut down after that it just
couldn't it was like a sympathetic
response that is some mess acting right
there's no really like why don't you
know all these publications ask the real
questions they don't know how method you
are I'm locked in yeah
mmm for my friends like I feel make her
friends but I'm not an actor I don't
want to be like I'm seeking game no
that's the headline for this oh my god
actor I'm trying to go to auditions
Mitsuki : trying to go to auditions yeah
Mitsuki : hm you trying to but you know
if you get when you get to a certain
status and you become like like at like
your own carrot mix ki think I don't
want you for just to play you exist to
just play yourself roles probably I just
like I'm not that I'm not good at it and
there are people who are good at it and
I feel like there are a lot of jobless
actors who are who like are really good
at acting they should get the part and
also I think my thing is when actors
like famous celebrities trying to
transition into music I [ __ ] hate it
oh yeah and so I don't want to do the
same thing to actors I feel like actors
would hate me if I like casually acted
in a movie or a TV series or rappers do
it all the time yeah but rappers are
free to do whatever they want I feel
like
you gotta mix it all
[Music]
miski can you help come come up with a
jingle for Tony's construction business
it's fictional yeah yeah Tony
oh no no beats a jingle there's no beats
no beach a jingle can't be cool okay
okay
Tony's construction mm that's it oh boy
and then the whoever the guy is on the
ad on the cheap ad is like this is okay
well hey I know poets
come talk to me Tony's construction hey
I know plumbing come talk to me
Tony's construction I know electricity
come talk to me
Tony's construction is thank you Sony's
console mini yeah Tony's construction
Tony's construction you need your walls
painted Tony's construction
that's all it is catchy it works I think
the people love it
yeah you you be all tender why you
travel it no no no muss with tender
no never tender no well I yeah no I've
heard about Raya I'm not on Raya but I
have a lot of friends I had a my friend
sess Tommy saw John Mayer on Raya and oh
my gosh I might ask us say I don't know
well just say that's a great name and so
she took a screenshot of it and she took
a screenshot of it and put it on social
media and I was like you're gonna get
kicked off of Riya for that but she
didn't so I guess it's yeah when you do
screenshot alright unless you know it
hey don't do that but she's still on
there also so Sami what's her name
so sue me so Sami Sami hey Sami that's
messy as [ __ ] [ __ ] you try to put John
Mayer out there like that floor well you
put how many likes you get Tommy she put
it on Instagram or Facebook Instagram
I hope the legs were worth it
celebrities of people - are you on right
what are you on I'm on Ryan mm-hmm
Anton do you hear that yeah who you
talking to
are you talking to viewers I haven't met
anybody from Ryan in a while but tinder
do you have any tinder stories just the
girls don't think as me mm-hmm
so you catfishing no no it's me and then
they just are adamant without any they
just assume that I guess I'm at that
place where they absolutely not it can't
be you and then I never end up meeting
up with them well they're listening
right now and they're just like more
like damn I should have believed I
should believe more this one girl went
on this whole thing you should love
yourself wherever you are
this is we don't as a whole you don't do
Matt you are important you don't need to
act like you're this other man just
wherever you are out there I want you to
love yourself she went on this whole
paragraphs of motivation self-help talk
to me thinking that I was that mean
that's what it makes it kind of funny
doesn't it I think those people who do
that actually are just saying it because
they need to hear it for themselves
yeah yeah yeah so she's being really
weird is there is there like video stuff
on tinder maybe you can like take a
video of yourself doing that and then
being like hey look I'm actually tinder
zombie no it's all pictures Oh pictures
are looking a quick bio good pictures
but you can uh you can link your tinder
to your Instagram so that I could go to
your Instagram a copy hey check out
which you should you should write down
I'm really Hannibal on a piece of paper
take a picture put it on I should mm-hmm
get off of there it's a goddamn mess
yeah don't you believe in love in the
stairway do you
[Music]
that was an influential song because she
used auto-tune heavily yes yes yes that
was one of the first auto-tune hits I
would have to say sure really yeah
[Music]
paving the way for all the rappers after
her she yeah all these I can't give her
credit for this yeah all the rappers
really do you follow
what's that song come out I was in
elementary school what was like when you
was so-so you were moving around a lot
so you weren't really able to embrace
like the scenes of please oh yeah I I
grew up on purely top 40 music and I
would always be abroad like I'd be in
like a lot of countries where everything
came late so I'd get like the top hits
from like a year before or two years
before and so I tend to relate to people
who are a little older than me because I
grew up on their media you know I got it
I gotta say yeah your music because I
was just recently introduced to it
reminds me a lot of are you familiar
with like like like the old Sub Pop
artists like in the 90s that label Sub
Pop it sounds like you would have fit
right into that era that scene like
who'd like like you're talking Nirvana
sup no no no more like Sunny Day Real
Estate is like those kind of like indie
bands that were kind of like she
[Music]
because I was on like those like little
mail-order things where they would send
you like a like a VHS tape and then
they'd just be like check out these
bands that we have and they'd be all
these indie rock bands but they would
always have like these unique sounds and
they were all like very DIYs
[Music]
[Music]
I actually never listened to those bands
I think I write pop music but with DIY
production yeah yeah that's exactly yeah
yeah so I think you would have fit right
into that kind of like it wasn't exactly
grunge it was before like emo was even a
thing yeah you know mm-hmm some people
even say Sunny Day Real Estate was the
first emo band mm-hmm oh no I should
check them out actually never break them
they're great they remind you of you
because it's very soft and very like
heartfelt and then they get into the
distortion and then they scream a little
bit and then they that's me that's the
dam so yeah what am i doing it's all you
you sound like like a 90s sub pop band
yeah you know instead I'm here today No
chillin when you were doing all that
that moving around would you ever say
okay I'm moving to a new place I'm about
to create a new persona for myself and
be somebody totally did I do that wait
I've said that in I've said that in
interviews maybe you've just how did you
know I really seemed like some you know
sometimes when people go to college they
over I'm gonna be this new person in
class about we're lovin my know my [ __ ]
was like this was like a little tiny bit
before social media was really a thing
so I could really show up anywhere and
be nobody and start from scratch
so I like truly experimented like I won
for one school I was like the popular
girl for another school I was like the
party girl from for another school I was
strictly academic like completely nerdy
another school I was kind of punky
another school like there was one school
in Virginia I went there and I decided
I'm not gonna talk to anybody and so the
whole year I didn't talk to anybody I
was that weird girl who just literally
wouldn't talk to anyone and at the end
of the year I entered the talent show
and I sang I will always love you
nice and then everyone yeah I killed it
I know children and then
and I thought that was really that was
like a joke for me anyway
that I thought was funny like slow build
yeah this quiet girl who's never touched
anybody just an epic song tune you gotta
say that from the bottom of the art I
just loved it I just loved watching the
audience reaction just their faces
changing as I sing from like that quack
girl that new kid who's never talked a
oh [ __ ] wait she's actually singing oh
[ __ ]
yeah you went then you went in a and I
went in and then I left the school
that's great
yeah I noticed last night at the show I
like how like direct you are with your
audience you just kind of don't you
don't play games with them you're like
all right go and play this hit now yeah
and then you're like all right so this
is the last song and no I'm cool yeah
just go home well you you weren't you
don't play games
I don't play game you don't play it what
is that you just don't like doing
encores and you just you just direct
like what's what I just I don't know I
mean I I do all encores often just cuz
like I feel like audience members feel
like they've been cheated if you don't
do an encore but and so sometimes I do
it but sometimes I'm really not feeling
the whole schtick of like ok I'm going
off stage but everyone knows I'm coming
back on and I'm gonna house lights are
still there yeah and I just like let's
not do that
you know but I still do that sometimes
when the audience like will keep
clapping and they start booing if you
don't do an encore and that's how to do
an encore but otherwise I just don't
want to do it you should do covers as
your encore I do actually
yeah yeah what'd you do I did well I do
a lot of like I did Calvin Harris's how
deep is your love
okay but like a grunge rock version of
it I think it's on the Internet
what do you do on the Internet
work I look up I look up dumb videos I
look up what my peers are making mm-hmm
their ticket prices how do you feel how
do you feel competitive know that
competitive what I do I do I will look
at if I see if I'm playing a venue a
comedy venue or any type of venue I like
to you just to see what other people are
charging for show you want to know what
your mm-hmm the marketplace is
especially certain cities you approach
differently you know where do you do
well I mean most spots lately I've been
touring for a good amount of time now
but so here
san Francisco's yeah any hapless
Minneapolis I mean the place is just the
road is pretty you know this kind it
gets to be kind of straightforward with
you go to a place a lot then more people
come to yourselves you go once it might
be okay you go back the second time some
of those people tell their friends or
the people that didn't come the first
time and see it so that's what I found
so the cities that I've been going to
for a while Milwaukee Minneapolis Boston
Philly those type of places do well it
that's good you really have to build but
sometimes I get bitter when like really
young like 16 year old major label
artists just like tour for the first
time in like thousands cap rooms and I'm
just like man I like toured for years
and years and just like shaved off years
of my life to be on the road it aid the
road the road ages yeah and then y'all
can just all right it was miss key what
you weren't you weren't getting those
emails after this yeah get those emails
that's what did you get even did you do
email lists oh I mean I booked my own
tours in the beginning and then it got
to a point where I got so busy that I
needed to hire
other people it's just like I've I've
expanded really gradually but just like
I've always been indie so sometimes when
I see people immediately kind of get to
that comfortable spot I've never been on
the label no I am on I want but I'm on
debt oceans which is like an indie label
okay yeah okay mm-hmm but I don't know I
mean I don't regret touring a lot it's
just like it was a lot of a lot of
winding yeah work especially when you're
a man and you got to carry your drums
and guitars and [ __ ] yeah and just like
sleeping and friends and friends and
friends of friends is like floors and
like punk houses and like haunted houses
I've only recently started to stay in
hotels but before that it was like my
friends friends friends aunt has like a
living room that you can crash in you
know I've done that we've I think all
three of us have done that yeah I don't
like it because I sleep do you really in
on the plane sometimes as well I don't
yeah when the movie did is really I just
can't let you sleep in them I sleep well
on the plane I sleep I can't I can't
sleep in vehicles whatsoever you can't
sleep on the plane
mm-hmm would you take xanax Mike well
awesome mom okay oh you should get Anzhi
quasi melatonin was equals sequel is the
night is Mike well Michael made it but
they realized people were taking Michael
just to sleep so they made sequel which
is like without any of the cold medicine
[ __ ] and just the [ __ ] that makes you go
to sleep oh yeah you should that I love
that stuff so then the new ad is without
all the coughing stuff you have good
sleep medicine so now it's just so you
could sleep better so yeah it's Z Z is
equal gotcha I'm gonna take it with a
Red Bull just to see you happy yeah
right just let them Duke it out yeah
Duke it out in my body I heard about
people what's the ambient I heard about
people that take ambien just to trip out
oh yeah like I said take ambien and stay
up yeah I got a homie who likes to draw
he's a good illustrator and he said
he'll take an ambien wait for it to
start kicking in then drink some coffee
and
drawing yeah and he says the trips he
makes some weird stuff and it yeah I
want to try it I think that could be the
your different school personas that
could be some type of TV show or
something
yeah that's a great idea actually just
somebody just being different everywhere
what what what year was the popular girl
phase freshman year that was freshman
yeah and so you did you go in with a
plan you know what I wanna I wanna have
good posture I'm gonna kinda yeah yeah I
kinda I mean doing that every year of my
life kind of [ __ ] me up in the long
run cuz it was like Who am I crazy but
okay but yeah it's being you know part
of the popular crew is actually not that
hard you just have to kill certain parts
of yourself and then be really outgoing
good what you have to kill um just like
empathy yeah and also just like I like
to be alone I like to hang out by myself
I like to do quiet person things but you
can't do any of that you have to hang
out with everybody need be nice to
everybody like always be down to joke
around sacrifice my grades went down
that year yes I just was fooling around
all the time when you're a social person
is hard to keep your grades up because
you're just like I gotta go hang out
with this person and that person then
catch up with people yeah then what was
your final GPA
I don't remember high school yeah it's
pretty high I was pretty good in school
otherwise but I think I was really good
in school because I learned early on
that if you're if you're like a standoff
[Laughter]
that's a weird one if your grades are
really good then teachers can't say [ __ ]
to you like even if you're kind of a bad
kid they can't scold you because you're
late
well look at my grades I'm doing
everything you want me to do so that's
true [ __ ] off and so kids out there just
keep your grades up and then you can do
whatever you want yeah that's that's
society mm-hmm that's America America
which you do you wanna uh you want to
live somewhere else you want to what's
your ideal place are you gonna travel
forever do you have a five-year what's
my five-year plan
what's your five you are you my business
manager I would one day I would like to
buy a house but that I think that will
be much later yeah I I realize you can
live anywhere it doesn't matter where
you're living really notice you can just
live anywhere a little bit well you have
uterine you just realize you people just
live everywhere and you can make a life
and there there's no I feel like it's
the same with like finding a soul mate
like the idea of fighting us owns full
mate there's never really any one place
that you're meant to be you can just
live anywhere and like live your life
and also moving away to somewhere else
won't change your life because you still
have to deal with yourself and you still
have to live with yourself I think it
could change your life
plus there's a general there's a general
thing that you're particularly - like oh
yeah I'd rather live on a farm or I'd
rather live in a big city where
anything's accessible so yeah you know
like what I don't want to live in Fresno
what's your beautiful lutely what's your
beef absolutely founded you should make
a story just make up a story yeah just
to back back up this beef that's it
make up one time one time in Fresno in
Fresno powers doing a comedy show and
doing the show I did a joke about
military folks and then I roasted this
one [ __ ] and he tried to fight me
outside my dream room that happened in
Fresno but that was a that was a real
story from Providence Rhode Island
Providence remember if you were on these
gigs it was a comedy club run oh wait
right before or right after Boston wait
retell this story I wasn't paying
attention I was so distracted military
oh so I was doing I used to do this joke
about this guy I did a show the bit was
about how I like the military wider you
know you know I respect the military but
you know why you in full uniform at this
Apple I think I've heard this yeah yeah
why you fool uniform with his Applebee's
right now and what's going on here I
think this is a [ __ ] Newt result and
so this one guy was I'm in the military
you need to respect the troops and then
I started roasted ham with your reserve
by a black crowds going crazy he just
feeling so he was waiting outside my
green room he wanted action they made
him leave that was only time somebody I
think at least he was waiting outside of
your green room not outside the venue
because outside the venue is that like
when you're not safe anymore in the
green room like they're still security
what's scary is what's scary is I had
that - - like people waiting outside the
venue and that's always scared just to
speak in a hug right whatever fight you
there was a swan show there's this one
well not really a show but it was in
Kansas City Missouri and there's this
guy in like full camo gear just like
waiting outside the show for it not just
for me but for like kids just like
waiting to fight somebody he just wanted
to fight somebody did he say that are
you justice so men no no no no I
shouldn't you know I shouldn't
discriminate against kammo he kept going
up to KITT like kids like teenagers who
are just like scared shitless and
they're like what we're good like we're
good and trying to get to their car and
this guy was like what's up what's up
and like trying to fight your friends I
would say your fans their children
they're not looking for a fight no
they're not they don't look like they're
looking for a fight yeah it's really bad
you should have you should approached
him know he had knives like visible on
his like hip and stuff we didn't have
any guns but yeah he had knives on him
that can't be legal with knives on your
waist
you know it's Kansas City man it was
late at night late at night in Kansas
City Kansas City don't give a [ __ ] you
know why there's a Kansas City Missouri
and a Kansas City yeah [ __ ] is lawless
out there man and they like beef over
like companies too so it's funny like
don't like make bids on big companies
and they'll just keep like the companies
will just keep crossing the borders
because they're getting like better
deals on the other so they just keep
going is silly as [ __ ] every year like
they'll be like all right well Foley
they do unite you know they're being
used by all these companies if only
they'd the government's a government
issue but I don't want to get into that
I almost bought a pinkie ring
in Vegas at a pawn shop you should have
why didn't you I couldn't get him proxy
to the price I want it at a pawn shop
yeah just pay the man
I mean who else is this part I was empty
it didn't seem like there was a lot of
volume of people coming in they're
looking at the pinkie rings particularly
I think is a buyers market and he wasn't
really the bin and you know says he
wasn't really in a bit I realized I
didn't really need a pinkie ring I mean
no one needs a pinkie ring but that's
not the point the point is to have a
baby
thank you I thought but yeah I didn't I
didn't want a pinkie ring for that price
what I actually like is the thumb ring
it's it's not that popular but it
actually looks pretty cool to just have
a ring here you rock a thumb ring
sometime you just liked it I do
sometimes but it's just cause like I
would get a ring I would buy like
jewelry online and then it wouldn't be
the right size but I want to wear it so
I got really creative I'd like weird on
my thumb yeah back in the 90s the the
thumb ring was a hard court that the
hardcore game is it the hardcore kids
would rock the thumb rings oh [ __ ] the
[ __ ] thumb ring man
well you know I listen to shellac Wow
were you hardcore I mean I a lot of
friends are into it and I liked a lot of
shellac I'm a big Steve Albini fan and I
like a lot of that stuff like the Sub
Pop stuff I was talking about but I
think I was more into the punk side than
the emo side but I did grow up on a lot
of rock music but like as soon as I
discovered wu-tang you know I was like
oh [ __ ] I got this is my this is where
this is my pocket
it's funny how venues everywhere across
America look like they used to be a
hardcore kid I mean venue security
people every venue in America like the
security people the staff people in
venues they all look like they used to
be hardcore what is that like what is it
is there are there like venue recruiters
at hardcore shows like hey have you
thought of being a security guy you know
they're tough guys usually yeah yeah hit
get some tattoos mmm come back you come
in with no tattoos no you don't beer
dolls have you ever heard of bigger
dolls now so beer dolls usually gold or
like heavy metal shows and they got the
big beer
and they're really in the craft beer Oh
beer dough's that's like a certain genre
of musical fan I don't know about that
there's big big-ass beards big bellies
like and they're like beer
Hey spouts I'm happy for them
everybody needs friendship you know yeah
yeah do you have any beer dough fans not
that I know of
probably me maybe on the internet
secretly maybe in their room they're
listening to my music yeah because they
can't listen to it in front of their
beard old friends cuz then they'll think
they're soft yeah but you know what
beard our fans I'm here for you you can
listen to me privately in your rooms
[Applause]
it's secret
just
[Music]
my thing only has like one only has non
cool effects this thing just to
experiment there we go
you know what I was uh I didn't I found
this out yesterday because of its
proximity to Asia Hawaii is where meth
first popped off in America I don't have
to do with what are you trying to say
because it's the closest to Asia and
meth was already popping in Asia was it
yeah I mean is he got it to Hawaii I
thought it cuz they cuz somebody this
comedian yesterday Andrew Schultz he was
telling me Oh a lot of people do a lot
of meth in Hawaii
why are you doing meth you know white
just serve do something just chill stuff
but meth is heavy down here it's
actually really expensive though cuz
it's so small like real estate is so
expensive and it's actually expensive to
live there yes yeah sorry meth prices
are higher problem right yeah maybe's Oh
meth is fascinating I'm more surprised
by the fact that meth came from Asia
what part of Asia mmm I don't know I
didn't what you're not up on your
history of meth I just really got into
this yesterday you got into meth like
yesterday my math research my deep mouth
a little baggie left behind
yeah did you put it in a wine like I
said to take the turn podcast
Matt yeah
Methos a weird-ass drug though I've
never done it have you ever done
adderall because that's pretty much
clean that's what it is pharmaceutical
grade meth so if you've done adderall
then you know what meth feels like I
don't know I've never done met but I've
done plenty of adderall then how do you
know it's like adderall I mean because
people that I know that I've done
methods just or actually you know what
the actual chemical makeup it's like
it's very very close you are getting the
like scientific facts yeah it's like you
know they're both on feta means one just
is medical grade and controlled versus
the other ones made in a bathtub oh now
I'm thinking like there's probably a lot
of people who need to be on adderall but
can't afford it and they're just
self-medicating with math no I don't
think people are like I have ADHD I'm
gonna smoke meth I think it's my guess
you you arrive at math you don't like
you don't yeah your goal isn't math you
just find yourself math at some point
you probably started with adderall and
then your doctor cut you off because we
had the twiki and then you went to the
streets man you started smoking that
meth I just wonder what the goal is with
meth because sometimes our people
partying for a week straight yeah whoo
oh it's just staying up for like days
yeah that's like the thing about methods
like they say you could do like a very
small amount and then stay up for like
[ __ ] three days straight are you
trying to beat a video game what is the
focus I would never want to be awake for
more than 48 hours 20 is excessive 20
hours straight yeah I need a break from
myself no yeah any drug that lasts
longer than like six hours is too much
for me it's like alright let's have a
come down here I can't even do we did a
Bulls cuz it's like it's still going on
when you're like you feel done you're
like
okay I get it like I feel good it's fine
and then you're still high I can't do it
that's my problem with acid is that like
I like acid but the fact that I've had a
12-hour trip before and like an hour
eight I'm just like Jesus Christ it's
too hot go away did you worried where
did you trip last time my last time I
tried yeah
mushrooms are acid I mean whichever you
would like to share mushrooms not too
long ago actually it wasn't mine I just
did it by myself in my apartment here
right here no actually I used to live I
just moved into here like in February so
no one's been on mushrooms in this
apartment yet not yet you need to
christen it I have some if you guys want
to do some but yeah I mean last time I
did it was great because I felt like
there was like another entity in the
room so I felt like I was like laughing
at my like I felt like someone was lat I
was having thoughts and I felt like
someone was laughing at my jokes oh
that's so nice so weird every comedian
wants that just like yeah just one yes
laughs partner there that's what it felt
like there was like another entity that
was like well I actually get sleep
paralysis so I have experienced that but
I do too in the negative way though yeah
yeah I think that's why I like spooky
stuff those like shadows are coming in
joy yeah I've had that before too mm-hm
it's a terrifying scene cos is rough I
get it oh that's why I get that on the
plane too okay what you have to do when
you're having it
what you have to do is what I do and I
get it is what because you know it's
happening you know it's sleep paralysis
so you just count numbers well I do
anyway I just go okay one two three and
I just like very calmly count numbers
and then I slowly wake myself up oh you
should try it just count numbers I just
do you talk to people next to you on the
plane sometimes really yeah oh that's
awful do I initiate yeah no like I'll do
like the quake at the beginning at the
beginning you're like by the way I might
just fall asleep and yell but it's fine
well yeah okay you don't call the flight
attendant I'll call the flight attendant
I like to drink orange juice after that
tweak out that do you check your
instruments or do you take it with you
onto the plane I take them with me
always so you always so you always get
the oh so you're a musician huh no
people hate instruments on the plane so
because it takes up so much space weird
amount of space so there's no there's
only negativity every time I have to be
like I'm sorry can I please like it's
it's my baby I really need to take it on
the plane [ __ ] and they [ __ ] good
and they try to try to make me check it
and then I have to like cite these like
laws where I'm like I say I'm allowed to
take it on the plane and then it's like
a whole thing but every time it's a
negotiation you have your base you play
the base yeah I saw you were playing the
guitar - are you carrying both it
depends on what show if I'm playing solo
at a college show than I play guitar and
I take a guitar but with a band I take
bass okay yeah yeah it's like yeah I'm
so when I do shows with him I always
have my like DJ gear with me and it's
the same thing it's just a weirdly
shaped backpack and it takes up and then
people yeah you get to look but then
sometimes people are like that's [ __ ]
cool looking backpack
you need last time I didn't tell you
about this through TSA
[ __ ] thought I was steve aoki oh
he was like hey hey yeah DJ huh
cuz he saw my [ __ ] going through yeah
it's like yeah yeah anything goes he
goes you're a guy who puts the cake in
people's faces right no no no no more
than once
I've had people straight-faced ask me is
that a violin and like I'm Asian but no
it's a guitar
why is how would this be a violin
they're just like trying to force like
force a narrative ya know when we
randomly saw Kanye at the airport and uh
in Minneapolis yes Ocana Minneapolis did
he have a posse no didn't he what he
strolled up just a person he came in
with a fur coat on a fur coat and no one
bothered him like when he got up to TSA
Ocana but it was it was a chill day at
the airport I remember trying to piece
it together in my head
wise Kanye and Minneapolis look online
he didn't have a so many Apple isn't
okay just wanted to visit Oh Kanye doing
a song with Prince yeah that's where I
was at yo he must be doing a song with
Prez brain went immediately did that
gotta be doing some Prince that's what I
actually that's a mood for famous people
just like cuz no one would expect it so
even if they see you they're like that
can't that can't be kind yeah yeah he
went he was going through the regular
preacher like he but I didn't notice him
at first because it's pretty hit the
like hood over his in face and then kind
of lifted it up and I'm like I look at
Hannibal I think we both realized that
at the same time like is that how was it
yeah it was weird
cuz he was right in front of us Wow
checking his bags like everything like I
think I saw him later that year and uh
he came to one of the shows Chappelle
was doing at Gramercy and I said hey man
we saw you in Minneapolis and I was
thinking he was doing a song with Prince
is this true he like nah but I like that
idea
why was he just doing regular flying I
mean he's big and rich enough
- just take private Jetson maybe he was
trying to write a song about being a
regular person doesn't do that [ __ ] with
Cinnabon at an airport I need to fly on
the shuttle I love the show and I wanted
to sign up for SkyMiles credit card yeah
that Minneapolis Airport is huge - so I
could see that him being like yeah I
want to get the airport experience
yeah that must have been it yeah yeah
let's just leave it at that
nothing so my last celebrity encounter
at an airport was Margaret Cho and I sat
down at the gate and I realized she was
sitting right across from me and I
didn't know I didn't want to bother her
but I kind of wanted to say something
like hey like I'm Asian too but I didn't
talk to her but she was big you should
just say hey agent ooh I know there was
just like another Asian person like
right there and I was like ooh and I
mean it wouldn't have made me special
but I really wanted to talk to her but
she just sang a song for her I should
have right there yeah Margaret Cho
[Music]
like an EDM Margaret - Margaret itself
I like yourself Margaret Oh Margaret Cho
do you like Cinnabon Margaret oh I'll
get you a Cinnabon and a shake and we
can smoke Margit oh do you wanna swap
what city will you go to when you get on
the plane
Margaret oh I really wanna explain my
fandom for you I'm Asian to this bull
market oh I'll make a song for you
Margaret oh you miss her when was the
last time you hang out with her I don't
know I don't know her like that I think
we've done a show or two together also I
might be lying and making up stuff
mm-hmm sometimes you feel like you know
people that's what happened we will meet
sometime people like hey or you just see
somebody so I think I've done a show a
market show mm-hmm at a festival some
they need another sound
miss King
[Music]
mints
a question plane if you know you know
how young jeezy goes eh or waka flocka
goes Flocka or bow-bow-bow or jay-z goes
is she boy or like Mike will made it
yeah what would your I mean I don't know
with his voice it's miss key [ __ ] Oh
actually can you do that and can I make
that my voicemail it's boots of course
that's good that is good I think I think
it's important for your catchphrase to
not be done my by you just like Mike
will made it is done by a random girl
voice right I think that's better a Rick
Ross has Maybach Music yeah wait what's
up with the playboy card either that's
been able to produce it oh yeah you want
to come in
it's weird cuz they just drop all the
music and the neck just comes in yeah
[Music]
every Rock running running shoe in Eddie
yeah you are you familiar with playboy
kardi kind of it's like all of his songs
like the music will just drop out just
hear any other room there at the wall I
like that one though cuz it's just so
odd yeah I will slim will splice it in
you'll hear it miss key if you if if it
had to answer right away what would you
ask the universe I was gonna say why but
that's so stupid I think if you wanted
to ask the universe question and get a
real answer you do DMT you're really
into the drugs yeah DMT I'm done yet
[Music]
[Music]
come on man when the bars gonna come in
I just thought that no I thought the
beat bus
I thought the beat was a pretty dope as
an instrumental so I tried to keep my
input on that piece very minimalist it
was a choice I was saying yeah it just
felt like a good production that you
guys made it was a group think yeah I
made a choice just to keep it and I did
that to myself
and then it sounded alright and so I
just kept doing this a big jump it I be
usable what's your what's your favorite
bar when you think what you of yourself
or your lines when you think about lying
a crazy line you get way damn damn miss
key that was a good one so yourself you
say that to yourself sometimes I say
that to myself all the time I'd say I
want to love that falls at fat as fast
as a body from the balcony I was really
proud of that yeah mm-hmm I like it when
lyrics are very physical there you make
like really physical metaphors I think
that's pretty good
that was one there you said stare look
at me up and down naked and then I
forget the rest I'm not I don't know
what you're talking about
I was on a song of yours I know but you
write you got a lot of songs I got I got
four albums Jeff levels mhm
look oh look look me in in my eyes when
I come yeah that's what it is that's a
different one well sure no that's a
lyric I was just trying to think of what
where else do I say look mm I can't
remember
can you try singing it
[Music]
fussing he might Hulk out and flip the
table you ever had sex to your music
accidentally oh oh oh that sounds awful
yeah I'd just be thinking about the
composition like I'd be having sex but
then I'd be like oh [ __ ] I should have
like fixed that in the production and
then I would be distracted even when my
friend's music is on do you put your own
comedy on when you're having but I have
like popped up on TV I've been making
out with a girl or somethin does it make
you feel better though like yeah I'm on
TV
I'm the man it depends on no no it
depends on the moment in what's going on
how much do you play up your celebrity
when you're dating I don't
is that a bad question I'm sorry you can
pass if you want no I'll play it up how
like how much do you kind of like use it
to your advantage
neither how conscious of or are you
trying to like be completely normal guy
like let's not touch on that that's kind
of it's tough I mean because isn't that
just my job is kind of your whole life
it's my life so it's uh yes so I mean
you know a lot of my life is going to
show even you know watching stuff if I'm
not working so it's uh if you can't talk
about it then you can't talk about
anything yeah and if you go i mean if
you hanging out with me we're probably
gonna go to some type of event or
something like that you know whis can be
kind of dicey yeah sorry because you get
I've had situations where I've brought
people into places where they didn't
know how to act they get a little they
get starstruck caught up and lost in the
sauces Hannah I've had to pull some
ELISA let's get out of here you stop can
you stop stop bothering his man please
can you please stop bothering Kanye he's
just trying to
he's just trying to buy Lego Forbes 100
yeah let's get out of here sorry about
her I also I also can't do like I don't
know how to say this nicely like like I
don't want to say nor me parties but
just like parties or like get-togethers
where there's no art people or
entertainment people because I don't
know what to talk about anymore because
my whole life is just kind of like
making music or just like being around
other artists so like extended family
get-together is where it's just like
what do you even talk about like I can't
I don't know anything about sports I
don't know how to talk about regular
business stuff I don't have a
nine-to-five what do you what do you
talk about I get free I freeze up you
know as you gotta do we gotta read a
Dale Carnegie book how to win friends
and influence
step 1
you got a are you talking to somebody
you got to touch them on the shoulder
and look them in the eyes
always remember people's names and say
their name a lot when you talking to
them you actually read it so there was a
point in your life where you were like I
need to figure out how to there was a I
remember Hannibal went through it like a
adderall and self-help book phase oh the
way he would write notes and have just
like three or four self-help books I
respect that you like are trying to be a
functional part of society I remember
one time where I sit in first class we
were going somewhere and you had like
three books and you had your notebook
and you're like I'm gonna get into the
self-help [ __ ] in public right before we
take off he was out that's lasted two
audio books recently okay like the image
of you like on a plane like yelling from
just like being asleep and in front of
you are three this guy is not
[Laughter]
but I just recently started audio books
I don't know what is that if you have
something that you've been
procrastinating on or there's something
you really want to motivate yourself to
do instead of doing your head I say you
wanna you're just trying to just some
simple just where you tired as [ __ ] you
only a few hours sleep and you got to
get out of bed you wake up instead of
hitting the snooze button you do a
countdown to yourself five four three
two and then I think the countdown gets
you going that works I was gonna say
that yeah that's a that sounds easier
said than done I don't that just you
count down the five and jump out of bed
and you just yeah you just the the
something about the brain the count
is it kind of like with with with
parents with their kids like you got it
right now let it go I'm gonna count to
three one and then kids always like just
like have to do what the parents is
saying
because they're counting is it like that
where something about counting yeah well
it's just where you is something with
the wired of the brain where you you
take action a theme of this podcast and
is counting yeah sleep paralysis where
Alice's getting up getting up five
second rule-- five second rule-- food to
know applies to food hmm what else but I
just in general I like to put myself in
situations where you had where I have to
do something versus being always totally
prepared
we're physicists my last tour I didn't
have a show I had a couple minutes of
jokes but I didn't wanted to sit and
write the whole [ __ ] mm-hmm so I just
booked some shows in Rochester Minnesota
just to work just jazz improv and I had
a few jokes but I will be booked maybe
four or five shows there and by the last
show just the necessity you know okay I
don't have a show but there's people
here so I have to do so they pay money I
have yeah so now that sense of urgency
made me you know now I had a right you
know I've created this deadline for
myself and so then I did these chosen by
the last show I had something that was
close to horrible and so did we add it
shows we went to Minneapolis after that
I got confident and just did well so I
just like I just I am a proponent of
just where you just have to if you
create a scenario for yourself what you
have to do some [ __ ] then it just it can
be good or you can [ __ ] up there's that
part but you know no I should do
something I agree with that and I tend
to just say yes whether I know I can do
it or not I just say yes anyway and then
I figure it out I feel like that's a
good way to throw you something that'll
wind you saying right yeah yeah breathe
in a reasonable fashion horse I think ya
know
I agree with that that's good that's a
good philosophy
have you ever bombed doing that just
doing just like winging it not winging
it but you know what I mean
jazz improv in with shows yeah I mean if
it's a smaller show what I'm just trying
out new jokes
it's just it could happen where you just
figuring out where a joke is placed in a
set or you know stuff might not work for
a particular crowd or sometimes what
happens with crowds might have a certain
expectation of Who I am going to be and
then I quickly say some [ __ ] that wipes
that
oh he's not he's not that character from
television mm-hmm broad city so a lot of
times people would be you know people
think you're that character yeah this
nice dentist guy but my sensibility can
lean you know I'm a nice guy equivalent
of like bomb it like a song like how do
how do you Bob how does a musician bomb
like what does that feel well I mean
like there's just playing the wrong [ __ ]
so the crowd is just talking over you
and not paying attention there I think
I've gotten to a point where like it's
not that I can't bomb but if something's
going badly I can deal with it or like I
just can go through a routine like I
think like I don't know I play a college
show all the kids just want to party
during a quiet song and no one's
listening I just keep playing it's fine
or if I play the wrong note like I just
keep going I don't let the show stop you
just keep playing I don't know like you
develop tactics to just keep going so I
don't I don't know if I've one time I
played when there was a like a a month
to month period where I was just
starting out and I knew I needed to
train myself like get better at
performing so I just played like this
was in New York City I played a
different dive bar like four times
a week or something and I would just
play deliberately to people who don't
want to hear me and like everyone in the
bar would just look like Charles
Bukowski just like that kind of dive bar
and one time I was playing and this
obviously coked-out woman was looking up
at me and she went while I was playing
would you kick her in oh no I was just
kept playing that's the thing you just
got to keep playing even if there's a
coked-out lady like yelling at you yeah
you know I notice too cuz there's
elements of the show where where it was
like cuz Lincoln Hall is so the
acoustics in there so you can hear
people breathing yeah and there'd be
moments the show ER it's like even when
I whispered I felt like I was
interrupting the show well for that
first for that show there is a there was
a period room I don't know if you
remember but like it wasn't my guitar so
I didn't have a strap lock yeah I saw
them yes it just came off they dealt
with it yeah you did actually that was
very professional the way you did it
because you're still singing and then
you were just kind of I made a man dance
out of it and everybody saw what was
going on but you did it very gracefully
thank you and I gotta say it was very it
was a professional way to deal with that
situation I'm really good at crisis
management I don't know I'm not I'd go
into panic mode I'm not good I'm not
good when things are going well that's
when I don't like it that's when I'm
panicking I like it when there's a
little bit of crisis then I can like
switch on wasn't for punishment
yes definite masochist for sure typical
Asian yeah just whipping my back
yeah it's not good enough it's never
good enough so I was you know I liked to
watch the audience when I'm at a show
so miski there was some people in your
audience they were like it was some
people like and it was some people kind
of night
what's your favorite my favorite is this
that's what I was gonna say you forgot
that 100 yo did you did you notice the
first like there was four people in
front of you and they had the camera
phones on you yeah how's that make you
feel well I'm of my generation my young
generation where that's normal yeah so
but they were in your grill and like
they it doesn't faze me like as you add
all that just happens I'm just used to
it like I feel like older rockers they
get so mad when people are recording or
on their phone and stuff also it's not
like comedy I feel like comedy shows
people that's content and you don't want
people putting that on the Internet
but with songs it's out there anyway it
doesn't faze you yeah it doesn't face I
mean it used I don't know I used to feel
like I should be bothered but I'm not
really I just don't pay attention you
were like literally like one foot away
from being able to step on well also
just people in the audience or phone
they have like a they have like a
watching TV effect like you're right in
front of them but for some reason people
think that you can't see them audience
members feel like they're looking at a
TV screen or something it's so weird you
you just like their faces are like or
just like they look so stupid or they're
talking to each other
no but they don't realize they don't
they don't realize that you can see that
it's so it's such a weird disconnect
it's true that's hilarious
do you realize how stupid you
work on your fans
open your eyes wipe that [ __ ] off your
face
but our position disguise
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
no place base in the place so yeah
people think they're looking at a TV
screen it's so funny
who's the biggest I'm going to do Lord
in marsh
I know that's gonna be in arenas but you
are at the pen mmm
after I can't talk when I smoke its
mellows hash oil how many days you doing
with Lord a month a month yeah nice hmm
it's not I don't know if I'm gonna sound
good cuz you're gonna do I shouldn't say
that actually I'm gonna sound great
please come to the shows you're gonna do
just fine I think he'll fit right in
with her fan base but it's me and then
run the jewels what any large you yeah
and the jewels
it's a weird tour who put this tour
together I don't know big probably Lord
right yeah Lords like I work out to this
I feel this put these together I want to
go to this I'm going to on the list
yeah I'll put you on the list yeah yeah
one of those yeah it's gonna be fun
you have a fine wait yeah it was wait
well what happened was more recently in
hostel oh yeah a Bonnaroo yeah yeah tell
her the story
tell me the story that wasn't crazy it
was a crazy day she had some technical
delays uh-huh and and I was really faded
and I was like yo Lord let me star for
you know you just really I was I can you
all jaws like yo you get up there do a
hop like y'all stop stop for the
Bonnaroo crowd it was nothing happen if
people were restless and I was like yo
let me and then they'd like escorted me
away I went back
you'll want me to go all this [ __ ] look
at this sometime let me do some time
like get him out of here please
yeah they really missed out that would
have been newsworthy that would have
been on Twitter yeah it'll be fun they
really missed out on that
let's see you miss all the shots you
don't take yes true I found out you know
I asked you miss all that it was it was
a hard that's one of those have you any
movie placements for your songs not
really actually hey I need to work on my
licensing Jesse honest tbh I was on
Supergirl that's it
Supergirl yeah you mean why work on it
what do you mean is there where you you
push for that yeah yeah I'm a lot of a
lot of artists who get on the shows they
could get their songs on their shows
actually have managers who are already
in the licensing world and so it's like
they're kind of like they're already I
don't know music supervisors and they
have their own artists and they're like
I'm just gonna put my artists on this
show all the time sounds about right
yeah and I don't have that so I better
work on it I push that [ __ ] yeah yeah I
better get in on the licensing industry
cuz that's some big money
yeah residuals yeah anymore okay you
want to sit on that cash I don't like
rjd2 to producer you know rjd2 right and
he he was under LP from Brenda Jules's
label and his song the beat that he made
got picked up for Mad Men it was like
that huge after that he never made he
did the theme song yeah he's not like
after that it felt like he just stopped
making music like I think he did some
[ __ ] did a couple of shows but he yeah
he can just do any ones now like off of
just those residuals he's like yo why
even make music anymore yeah I got a
bomb I'm I'm the guy who made the bad
man song
[Music]
Oh beautiful my turn water into wine but
that's not all broke the water shine
through shake the earth critted the code
of life radiated with energy the great
boat of life the spark sparkling through
the dark night the walk that took
forever without a think it's a good song
[Music]
that's that goes a did you ever hit an
SNL parody of that I think it was I
wanted to join him episodes you know Mad
Men Mad Men then ties cigarettes
cigarettes
[Laughter]
Jon Hamm is like I just recently met him
cuz he did a film with him Jon Hamm is
one of the coolest celebrities I've ever
met
he's just so [ __ ] chill he's probably
grounded cuz he was like a school
teacher first right he like time you
really hustled for a long time before he
was a famous actor I just you know I
think a lot of people just expect him to
be a douche bag like off because he's so
handsome I think that's what it is and
like he could just he seems like one of
those guys I could just get away with
anything he's just but just right off
the top when I met him I was like man
this dude is super [ __ ] cool like
just not know pretentiousness know
[ __ ] like he didn't have that persona
like I'm John [ __ ] Hamm which
he should good he couldn't get away with
it doesn't at all oh that's nice nice
guys nice a shout outs on him
Jon Hamm you've annoying random facts
and sit about that yeah but he was just
some yeah did some random [ __ ] and what
this many bricks were using this
Cathedral
I need another
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is some death-grip [ __ ] just this
business combine the nonstop
[Music]
[Laughter]
just like a machine all you got so yeah
but you should pitch it for licensing
your show in your show where you're the
dentist
yeah yeah yeah in a chaotic scene just
bad stuff in in a chaotic scene where
like Alana's really really really high
on an upper or something it would be
playing in the background while she's
going crazy that could be that could be
something do it if we if we come up with
some good stuff we could probably pitch
to them this is yeah we're going into
season five man no that's when you start
asking for stuff yeah lot of cool as
[ __ ] - she'd be like yeah yeah yeah
miski make some more money
risky with the ideas Mitsuki in the
house thank you for coming on the show -
oh thank you for having me it was really
fun yeah you're great guest oh thank you
I do my I try my hardest I do my best
we well not we but he decided on getting
you because he liked your pitchfork
under I think it's just cuz I went in
knowing the point of it like knowing
that it's not even about me it's about
entertainment yeah like I'm not gonna be
like well you know I think furbies are
nice but I really I don't know I'm not
really it's like not about that yeah I
look like [ __ ] though hotties
I was I had really bad posture and I had
just woken up and they're lighting I
looked really bad next time next time is
fine thank you
next time I have an appearance I should
work on my posture or not you have a bit
to a chiropractor oh my gosh I love them
I love them you should go it's it's
almost addicting because it's like they
tell you tell you what's wrong with you
and then they fix it immediately it's
almost like some kind of therapy which
is they would you know what I don't like
about chiropractors is that the it's
like okay you crack them back and did
some stuff okay it's questionable if
it's you know whatever but when they try
to sell you the shoes and like I don't
know I've gone to like Chinatown
chiropractor yes so yeah those are
better every time I go to a chiropractor
they always try to sell me like insoles
from my shoes like it just goes your
arches you're just find a chiropractor
in your local Chinatown and then they'll
you feel really actually I believe in
Chinese medicine yeah yeah me too some
of some of it well it's just I I would
like I'd sit in cars all day and then
I'd like hold an instrument I'd just be
out of alignment so I would like you do
acupuncture no I've never tried that
have you done that I tried it once when
I had after uh accident I had a couple
years ago my back was [ __ ] up and do I
think it was was he tapping he was
poking stuff in my foot and I felt like
the connection my lower back yeah
there's definitely what the [ __ ] yeah at
the bottom of my foot of some [ __ ] yeah
it was crazy like medical journals that
back up the science in to acupuncture is
just doesn't work for me like it works
for everyone else ya know once that [ __ ]
once he touched my foot in this she hurt
my back I said I don't need that in my
life
that's so much crap crazy it's crazy
when they do the face when people come
out with [ __ ] needles on their face I
did that before for cigarettes I went in
five sessions to quit cigarettes
I love cigarettes yeah so good so tasty
I love I don't smoke anymore but I still
I still get high did you kick it I just
got really sick and I couldn't smoke and
then so there was a period where I
didn't smoke anyway cuz I was really
sick and then how long have you been off
of it I quit when I was like 18 19 and
sometimes when I when I drank I liked to
smoke as well
I try not to and then it's bad because
every time every every time I like smoke
at a party just socially I feel the
effects I have to like you have to like
control myself for the next two weeks
after it really sucks yeah and the
smoking hangover sucks yeah I'm gonna
chain smoking it's worse than I think
the drinking hangover when you get your
lungs hurt in the morning yeah but I've
been vaping so it's cut my smoking down
I love so much especially when I'm
touring through like like Wyoming or
that kind of country where it looks like
a marble or ad anyway and then I just
like yeah you always have to be addicted
to something but it's like I get
something I'll make it something better
did yoga brah that sucks but what's
wrong with yoga is healthy no just a guy
who says you're I'm addicted to yoga bro
I'm gonna say that
that's my new tinder my new tinder
profile I'm addicted to yoga I'm
addicted to yoga bruh but then a lot of
girls who are like really into crazy sex
will get into you cuz they're like oh
yeah he can do some crazy positions and
he's got good breathing techniques but
then you have to follow through yeah so
yeah that's not good let's close it
close it down thank you so close to
death having me so
sails day misty
[Music]
thank you Miss scared
all right let's get out of you all right
thank you
[Music]